in 1961 soviet cosmonaut yuri gagarin
blasted into outer space
and as his vostok rocket blasted off
gagarin shouted cheerfully
that means let's go gagarin's 108
minutes in space was the beginning of
the space age
and an age of space heroes
gagarin was idolized at home and
traveled the world
cheered everywhere by jubilant crowds
his american counterparts
alan shepard followed by john glenn were
similarly lauded as courageous
adventurers
glenn later became a u.s senator and ran
unsuccessfully for president
moscow is go for docking houston is go
for docking
it's up to you guys the space race was a
cold war era strategic competition
between the soviet union and the u.s
with military overtones but it also had
a genuine air of
optimism and idealism seen by many
as the next great stage in the human
saga
and perhaps a force for global
brotherhood
around the world kids dreamed of growing
up to be space
men and women and liftoff of discovery
well things sure have changed from
symbols of national greatness and
demonstrations of dueling ideologies
space travel today is all about money
and ego russia actually started the rich
space
tourist trend offering seats on a soyuz
spacecraft for hefty fees
this july our dream will become a
reality
richard branson never shy of the media
spotlight will swoop space ward
aboard a virgin galactic spacecraft
from a base in new mexico followed by
amazon founder jeff bezos aboard blue
origin a week later
i want to go on this flight because it's
a
thing i've wanted to do all my life
what's really significant about the dmu
mission
the third space billionaire elon musk
says he's interested in taking
one of his spacex rockets to the moon
one day
and after that may be mars musk and
bezos are dueling for contracts to
supply the international space station
and
nasa's lunar lander branson wants to
create a space
tourism industry for well-heeled
travelers willing to pay
several hundred thousand dollars for a
quick jaunt
there is big money to be made that's one
small
somehow it all seems a little less noble
than
in the early days when the apollo
astronauts left behind on the moon
a plaque reading we came in peace for
all mankind
the new space tycoons may not have the
right stuff
but they've got all the bucks rob
reynolds al jazeera